do you know what blockchain is or not
really no so I want to challenge a no
I'm good I'm good freeze-frame um so
what is string theory well students
comes from this idea that people had to
blockchain is digital money yeah I
haven't explained it very well I thought
this look was the money no no no no no
the blockchain is not the money well I
guess that's really useful because we
can go for that one like I'm looking at
an infinite amount of time in the future
this would be like at an infinite amount
of time in the past so negative well it
would give us a hint as to what where
that Big Bang came from and like to keep
that this is really hard it's supposed
to be I just get to ask questions and be
like that doesn't make sense half day
you're like what kind of show have I
signed up like so if you think I did
definitely yes but I don't like it
honor that's fine there's a lot of
things in Massapequa don't like wait but
what is a string
it's like saying what's an electron at
the end of the day the answer is it's an
electron that's because there's nothing
else is it's a subatomic particle that's
just a bucket you'd put it in my
ministry I want to know now because I'm
gonna have to explain it at the end and
I don't
like a big dummy yeah yeah we are really
trusting this elevator now
but God's sake it's just digital - whose
side are you on man I'm on the side of
making things hard for you to ask what
is vibrating is not a question we can
answer I mean fine I guess
do I look out do I stay here what am i
doing hey hey you listen yeah this is
your home okay okay just leave me to rot
that's show biz baby
[Music]